Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittlav und.
Auch heute geht's mal wieder um äh Korona, nachdem sich die letzte Sendung mal ausnahmsweise wieder mit dem Brexit beschäftigt hat
Und es gibt äh Nachrichten, die wir mal kurz äh aufräumen wollen und zwar gibt es Nachrichten zu einem potenziellen Impfstoff, der jetzt demnächst vielleicht,
verfügbar sein könnte und dass es doch eine gute Gelegenheit mal wieder mit dem Lars zu sprechen. Lars Fischer, hallo Lars.
Ja wir haben uns ja in der letzten Folge gemeinsam, also mit der wir, die wir zusammen gemacht haben, ähm über Impfstoffe so im Allgemeinen unterhalten und da war doch so ein bisschen unklar, wohin äh die Reise wohl so gehen könnte. Sind verschiedene.
Ja Impfstoffarten durchgegangen und wie generell so mit Impfstoffen eigentlich verfahren wird,
Ja, diese Woche gab's die Nachricht, dass äh die Firma Biontech vorhat, äh jetzt eine Zulassung für ihren Impfstoff zu beantragen.
Dem wohl die Phase drei Tests mit dem Impfstoff ganz gut verlaufen sind
aber das ist ja jetzt noch nicht ein Zwischenstandsbericht, der hier veröffentlicht wurde. Das Ding ist noch nicht wirklich ganz da, wo es eigentlich sein muss. Korrek.
Da muss ich gleich mal quasi einschreiten, weil die beiden beteiligten Unternehmen Pfeifer und Björn Tech.
Ja ganz klar gesagt haben, sie planen noch keine Zulassung und zwar, weil
weil das ja jetzt tatsächlich noch ein Zwischenergebnis ist, dass sie gemeldet haben und sie wollen tatsächlich erst die Zulassung beantragen, wenn äh wenn
tatsächlich die nötigen Infektionen in der Versuchsgruppe erreicht sind und vor allem wenn bei.
Genug Leuten über ein hinreichend langen Zeitraum die nötigen Sicherhei.
Vorliegen und äh das wir,
Ende des Monats der Fall sein, sagen sie ähm,
Aber dieser dieser Zulassung quasi die die Notzulassung, die sie beantragen wollen, die ist ja in bestimmte Bedingungen gekoppelt in den USA und diese Bedingungen erfüllen sie noch nicht.
Ah ja, okay. Wa.
Ist denn nun in diesem Zwischenbericht äh konkret veröffentlicht worden.
In dem Zwischenbericht, das im Wesentlichen veröffentlicht worden äh,
wie viele Leute in diesem, in diesem Try, in dieser Studie
inzwischen entholt, dass er aufgenommen wurden äh und wie viele Infektionen es insgesamt gab, ist es
unklar, soweit ich weiß, wie viele Leute tatsächlich den Impfstoff, beziehungsweise die beiden Impfstoffdosen gekriegt haben, wie viele Leute das Placebo,
haben. Es ist unklar, äh wie viele Leute in der Placebo-Gruppe und in der Impf.
Tatsächlich jeweils infiziert waren. Sie sagen aber, dass äh
dass der äh dass der Impfstoff in der geimpften Gruppe im Vergleich zur Percebook Gruppe neunzig Prozent der Infektionen verhindert hat. Also die
Informationen, die vorliegen, sind tatsächlich unvollständig. Das ist auch äh,
viel kritisiert worden, aber wie gesagt, es ist nur ein Zwischenbericht.
Mhm. Justus, eine berechtigte Kritik oder weil's eben nur ein Zwischenergebnis ist, äh behalten sie sich die Veröffentlichung äh vor. Also am Ende muss es aber veröffentlicht werden, oder?
Ja am Ende müssen die Ergebnisse raus, sie müssen zumindest an die Behörden.
Werden und die Unternehmen haben
angekündigt, zumindest in dieser Pressemitteilung, dass es auch eine Publikation geben wird. Äh ob die Kriti.
Berechtigt ist äh na ja auf der einen, auf der einen Seite ist sie natürlich berechtigt, auf der anderen Seite ist das.
Eine Vorabinformation und
meines Wissens, ich verstehe nicht so richtig viel von Wirtschaftsrecht, meines Wissens,
Unternehmen in diesem Fall gar keine andere Wahl als die Öffentlichkeit per Pressemitteilung über dieses Zwischenergebnis,
zu unterrichten, weil äh.
Börsennotierte Unternehmen mir verpflichtet sind, kursrelevante Informationen zeitnah zu veröffentlichen. Das heißt ähm.
Sie mussten irgendwas veröffentlichen, aber man kann jetzt nicht sagen, na ja, sie haben jetzt schon Teaser,
hingehängt aus meiner Sicht. Sie haben jetzt so einen Teaser hingehängt und Daten zurückgehalten, sondern äh die Daten, die sie veröffentlichen
sollten müssen die relevanten Daten,
müssen nach dem Ende des Teils kommen und nicht nach dem Zwischenergebnis.
Okay, das heißt, diese Ankündigung war eher Wirtschaftsrechtlich erforderlich und äh weniger jetzt wirklich ein wissenschaftlicher Move, sage ich mal.
So habe ich das verstanden, ja. Mit der Einschränkung, dass mein äh dass mein Hintergrund da eher dünn ist.
Ja okay, gut. Aber was wissen wir denn jetzt? Also wie viele Leute haben denn an diesem Test teilgenommen.
Sie haben über vierzigtausend Leute tatsächlich in dieser Studie eingeschlossen. Äh die Studie.
Also diese Impfung besteht aus zwei Impfungen, ähm die im Abstand von drei Wochen gegeben werden
Und äh ja irgendwie etwas über achtunddreißigtausend
Leute haben, also wie gesagt, entweder die die Impfung oder ein Platz Zebo gekriegt, wie viel jeweils weiß man leider nicht
Was man natürlich auch weiß, ist die
ungefähre Natur dieses Impfstoffes, das heißt äh das was da quasi impft, das ist eine Ergan A, eine M RNA. Ähm das M steht für Messenger, das heißt diese,
RNA ist quasi gebaut wie eine wie eine,
A die genetische Information vom Erbgut.
Zu den Proteinfabriken der äh der Zelle transportiert, also das heißt dieser, dieser Ehrganar ist dazu gedacht quasi äh.
Direkt in die Reboujoon reinzugehen und in dein Protein übersetzt zu werden und das Protein ist in diesem Fall ähm.
Das Spike-Protein vom Saatkopf zwei Virus, das,
von der Challenge nach außen präsentiert wird und nur Immunreaktionen auslöst. Das ist das Funktionsprinzip, das weiß man. Man weiß auch, dass äh das äh Märgern ah in einer Lipidhülle, in Lip
Teilchen äh verpackt ist.
Also so einer Fettschicht.
Ja in einer in einer Art Fettschicht, die äh die für die Funktion dieses Impfstoffes oder uns nicht ganz irrelevant ist. Also man weiß schon einiges über das, was da passiert, was man eben noch nicht hat, sind die Klarenzahlen.
Wie wie wird denn dieser Impfstoff verabreicht.
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, Intraumuskulär. Es wird in den Muskel gespritzt, zwei, zwei Injektionen im Abstand von drei Wochen.
So und das bedeutet, dass hier dieser Wirkstoff.
Ich versuch's mal so ein bisschen mit meinem Verständnis äh zu beschreiben, enthält eigentlich nichts anderes als diese diese Fettstruktur, diese lipide und da drin ist.
Eine RNA.
Was er so mal grob gesagt, so eine halbe DNA, äh ein halber DNA-Strang ist, etwas anders äh kodiert, aber das ist letzten Endes auch nichts anderes als eben eine Aufbaubeschreibung, um etwas herzustellen.
Das gelangt dann aber auch in die Zellen rein.
Ja, das wird in die, in die Zellen aufgenommen,
ein sogenanntes Endosomme also das ist so ein kleines Membrasen
Brahnbläschen, es stülpt sich nach innen,
und aus diesem Membranbläschen muss dann die MRN auf
Äh in Cycoplasma, also ins Zellinnere kommen, wo wo.
Sie dann in das Protein übersetzt wird.
Und dieser dieser Transport, dieser Übergang ist natürlich extrem verlustreich. Ich habe heute eine äh eine Veröffentlichung gelesen. Laut denen quasi nur ein Zehntausendstel, der tatsächlich äh
Tatsächlich in dieses Endogom, in die Zelle aufgenommene,
ähm RGN A ist auch tatsächlich ins Zytoplasmaschaft, um da übersetzt zu werden.
Mhm. Das heißt, du musst schon in einer großen Menge geimpft werden.
Ja große Mengen sind natürlich relativ, weil wir hier natürlich unzählige Moleküle haben. Äh aber die
Menge und vor allem vor allem ähm
Die Frage wie oft quasi diese MRNA abgelesen wird, die wird ja in der Zelle nicht nur einmal abgelesen, sondern mehrfach, bis sie irgendwann abgebaut wird, wie oft das passiert
Äh quasi.
Äh quasi im Verhältnis zur Verlustrate, das ist eben auch ein wesentlicher Punkt. Also es geht ja darum, dass man möglichst viel
von diesem viralen Protein erzeugt, das dann nach außen präsentiert wird und diese Immunreaktion auslöst. Und da ist einmal einmal die Frage, wie viel muss man geben? Wie viel
kommt rein, kann man das irgendwie verbessern und wie oft wird diese reingekommene MRNA dann auch tatsächlich abgelesen.
Bleiben wir nochmal so ein bisschen bei dem was es tut. Also diese RNA ist ja quasi ein Bauauftrag ausschließlich für dieses.
Protein, was ich halt an dem richtigen Virus äh also was dieses Spike Protein ist, also das, was letzten Endes ja eigentlich auch den eigentlichen Angriff auf die Zelle äh ermöglicht.
Richtig?
Und.
Das ist aber auch das, wo dann eben das Immunsystem drauf geht und sagt, was ist denn das hier? Äh das können wir aber hier überhaupt nicht gebrauchen. Da fange ich mal an hier äh Alarm zu schlagen und das Immunsystem hochzufahren, um dann ähm,
Fresszellen zu erzeugen, die das dann eben auch
bekämpfen können, nur dass bei einer normalen Virusinfektion zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo das stattfindet,
Virus in der Regel schon äh den Körper zahlreich befallen hat und sein Unwesen treibt und sich selber
vermehrt.
Ja der, der entscheidende Punkt ist letztendlich, dass äh dass.
Und deren Stoffe, die GNA im Stoffe gibt's ja auch noch,
dieser Erbgut im Stoffe, die aktivieren ein anderes Verteidigungssystem, als wenn man zum Beispiel inaktiviertes Virus in die in die,
Bahnspritz, was beim RNA im Stoff vor allem passiert ist.
In der Zelle von diesem hergestellten Viralen Proteinfragmente.
In ganz spezifischen Molekülen, der so einen MHC Molekülen, Mensch ist zu komplettibility Komplex. Äh nach außen präsentiert werden
und dieses nach außen präsentieren, alarmiert Immunzellen, zeigt den Immunzellen dieses Fremde in der Zelle äh erzeugte
Protein
Und das stimuliert wiederum vor allem die Entwicklung von.
Also nicht wie bei anderen Impfstoffen äh vor allem.
Antikörper, sondern das, was hier stimuliert wird, äh das sind zytotoxische Teezellen,
darauf reagieren, wenn tatsächlich eine Zelle mit diesem, mit diesem Virus infiziert ist und virale Proteine nach außen präsentiert
Und diese diese äh,
Dieser T-Zell-Antwort. Das ist ähm.
Ist schon etwas anderes Prinzip als ein normaler Impfstoff und es gibt auch
gute Indizien dafür, dass diese Teezellantwort gegen,
eine recht hohe Bedeutung hat.
Weil es das besonders gut bekämpfen kann.
Ja, erstmal, also soweit ich weiß, dass uns nicht ganz das ist nicht ganz klar, warum gerade diese diese
Antwort äh bei Corona Viren relevanter ist als die, als die Anti,
paar Antwort, aber das ist etwas, was sich Studien in den letzten Monaten immer mal wieder gezeigt und angedeutet haben, dass diese Teezellen bei der Bekämpfung der Infektion wichtiger.
Sind und dass eben deswegen eine
Immunität, wie sie durch Erbgut in Impfstoffe entsteht, da eben auch eine eine gute, eine relativ gute Schutzwirkung.
Und äh diese,
geimpfte RNA oder Bodenärner im RNA, die beschreibt ja sozusagen auch nur dieses Protein, das heißt
Allein dadurch, dass der Körper dieses Protein erzeu.
Dem Körper erstmal so kein Schaden entstehen.
Erstmal nicht. Also äh es gibt keinen Infektionsrisiko wie bei äh wie,
Wir von Lebendimpfstoffen und so. Also dieses Risiko.
Gibt es nicht. Äh es gibt allerdings bei Erdgut im Stoffen, bei MRNA Impfstoffen äh.
Paar potentielle Probleme, die man, die man nicht ganz aus den Augen verlieren darf.
Ein Punkt äh ist zum Beispiel, dass dieser äh dass diese Hülle.
Diese Fetthülle ähm in früheren Versuchen mit äh,
gar nicht mit Antiviralen Impfstoffen, es gibt auch andere,
an denen experimentiert wird gegen Krebs oder auch gegen Stoffwech
Krankheiten und in früheren Experimenten haben diese Lipidhöhlen zum Beisp,
wir äh waren toxisch, wir haben toxische Effekte verursacht
Ähm es ist ein äh ein Aspek.
Eine andere, eine andere potenzielle Problem ist, dass äh die Bausteine dieser Ärgernahme.
Verändert sind. Also diese diese Märgern A, das ist quasi nicht das natürliche Abbild einer beliebigen MRNA, sondern die ist chemisch ein bisschen verändert, damit sie ein bisschen stabiler ist und häufiger abgelesen wird,
Ähm und auch eine wenige heftige Immunreaktion auslöst,
Also diese veränderten Bausteine.
Auch toxisch sein unter bestimmten Umständen
und dann gibt es eben auch das Problem, dass äh.
Die in Endojomen reinkommt. Also in diese Blase über diese Bläschen in Zelle aufgenommen wird. Die wird in diesem Bläschen noch durch spezielle,
Mustererkennung tr,
Toren erkannt, wenn diese Mustererkennungsrezeptoren anschlagen, dann lösen sie oft eine sehr heftige Immunreaktion aus und diese Immunreaktion
oder stand im Verdacht auch eventuell mit Autoimmunerkrankungen zusammen äh zusammenzuhängen. Das heißt, es gi
äh grundsätzlich gelten diese MRNA im Stoffhal.
Als sicherer, zum Beispiel als abgeschwächte Virale-Impfstoffe, aber es gibt auch so ein paar so ein paar Punkte, wo zumindest theoretisch Probleme auftreten können.
Jetzt sagt ja Björn Tech, dass sie ähm hier neunzig Prozent.
Wirksamkeit erzielen können, also wie genau berechnet sich das jetzt aus diesen Zahlen, die wir gehört haben? Also es gab siebenundneunzig Fälle, also gegen was.
Also wo wo ergeben sich diese neunzig Prozent heraus.
Na ja, man hat ja bei solchen äh bei solchen klinischen Versuchen normalerweise auf der einen Seite äh.
Impfung.
Bei der wir hoffen, dass sie wirkt. Auf der anderen Seite, da haben wir jetzt einen Placebo, also quasi äh man geht quasi durch diese äh.
Durch diese zwei Einsteche, durch diese zwei Impfungen durch, aber vermutlich wird das nur.
Natriumchloridlösung sein, die nichts Spezielles macht, das heißt ein Teil der Leute ist tatsächlich geimpft
Ein Teil hat nur eine Scheinimpfung bekommen
und sollte deswegen durch die Impfung natürlich nicht geschützt sein, weil sie nur Salzwasser gekriegt haben und jetzt kann man sich nach einer Weile angucken, wie viele Leute äh
haben sich denn in der geimpften Gruppe infiziert, wie viele Leute haben sich denn in der Kontrollgruppe in der ungeimpften Kontrollgruppe infiziert
und äh wenn jetzt in der ungeimpften Kontrollgruppe viel mehr Infektionen auftreten, als in der Impfgruppe ist das schon ein ein deutlicher Hinweis darauf, dass,
da offensichtlich eine Schutzwirkung ist und wie groß diese Schutzwirkung ist, kann man eben statistisch berechnen. Äh wie sicher man sagen kann, dass diese Schutzwirkung existiert und dieser Unterschied
nicht einfach durch ein durch einen Zufall zustande gekommen ist. Also man vergleicht quasi den Effekt.
In der geimpften Gruppe mit dem Effekt in der Kontrollgruppe.
Jetzt gab es siebenundneunzig Fälle hast du gesagt.
Das heißt, äh diese neunzig Prozent müssen sich ja eigentlich aus diesen siebenundneunzig Fällen herausrechnen. Das heißt irgendwie die allermeisten waren jetzt wahrscheinlich in der Placebo äh Gruppe und dann eben nur so ein Zehntel davon in der.
In der geimpften, in der wirklich geimpften Gruppe, so würde ich das jetzt mal lesen. Ist das richtig.
Genau voraus, Voraussetzung ist natürlich, dass man eine eins zu eins Aufteilung äh der achtunddreißigtausend Versuchspersonen in geimpfte und Placebo hat.
Also äh,
Das ist das ist der Hintergrund, wo man dieser dieser eins zu eins Aufteilung hat, also beide Gruppen gleichgroß sind, dann könnte man zum Beispiel auf der Basis äh
der der Daten, die wir haben, könnte man sagen, möglicherweise waren jetzt in der Impf,
nur acht infizierte äh und in der äh in der.
Neunundachtzig.
Genau, also das wäre ein Verhältnis. Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel zwei Drittel der Leute geimpft haben und nur ein Drittel äh Placebo bekommen hat.
Dann würden sich die Verhältnisse natürlich entsprechend diese Satzahlen ändern, das wissen wir nicht, aber grundsätzlich ja würde man das einfach so ausrechnen.
Jetzt ist es aber so, jetzt äh wir haben ja gesagt, das ist ja ein Zwischenergebnis äh sprich
Ein Endergebnis gibt es erst, wenn sie genug Fälle haben, damit es wirklich eine belastbare Zahl äh äh am Ende ergibt. So und da habe ich jetzt, was war das? Das waren hundertvierundsechzig Fälle,
Auftreten müssen.
Hundert, hundertvierhundertvierundsechzig. Allerdings muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, äh ich weiß nicht, wie sie genau auf diese hundertvierundsechzig kommen. Das hängt auch glaube ich so ein bisschen an der statistischen Ort
Auswertung und an der Aufteilung der beiden Gruppen.
Ja
Gut, das heißt aber dann müssten sie ja nochmal eine, also ich weiß nicht, ob das sozusagen.
Noch nicht aufgearbeitet ist uns diese Fälle schon gegeben hat oder ob diese Fälle erst noch kommen müssen, das das wissen wir auch nicht ne.
Das wissen wir auch nicht. Also sie was sich tatsächlich als Zeitrahmen gesagt haben war
dass sie quasi mindestens die Hälfte der Beteiligten für minde,
zwei Monate in dieser Studie haben müssen, um Sicherheitsdaten zumindest über diese zwei Monate zu bekommen
und das was tatsächlich ähm in der dritten Novemberwoche der Fall, also relativ bald, ob sie dann schon die hundertvierundsechzig Infektionen haben.
Weiß man natürlich nicht.
Ja. Wo finden denn diese Tests statt?
Da muss ich sagen, da muss ich passen, ich weiß, dass in den USA getestet wird. Ich weiß, dass
nicht nur in den USA getestet wird, aber welches, das ist ja eine multizentrische Studie bei so vielen Leut,
aber da müsste man tatsächlich in die Studienbeschreibung rein
um genauer. Die ist veröffentlicht, aber das weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich habe das einmal überflogen, aber da kenne ich keine Zahlen und Orte.
Ja gut. Gehen wir doch einmal davon aus.
Dass jetzt in absehbarer Zeit. Ich meine, sie sind ja jetzt schon relativ klar,
aufgetreten. Ich meine, gut, sie hatten da jetzt vielleicht irgendeine Mitteilungspflicht, aber es war ja die Aussage, war ja nicht ganz ähm
War ja nicht besonders zurückhaltend. Sie haben gesagt, wir sind uns relativ sicher, das funktioniert. Wir sie produzieren ja auch diesen Impfstoff schon seit längerer Zeit und wollen da halt mit mehreren Millionen Dosen irgendwie noch in diesem Jahr
auf den Mar
treten, wobei so ein richtiger Markt ist es ja nicht, sondern da gibt's natürlich dann entsprechende Aushandlungen und Zusicherungen, wer denn jetzt diese ersten Batches dieses Impfstoffs bekommt.
Äh es war glaube ich die Zahl äh ich habe so eine Zahl gehört, dass irgendwie hundert Millionen Dosen in USA und hundert Millionen Dosen auch in den äh auch in Deutschland äh sozusagen angedacht sind
davon werden dann sicherlich ein gewisser Teil auch noch anderen Ländern verfügbar gemacht werden. Da gab's ja entsprechende Absprachen zumindest in der EU.
Jetzt ist ja diese Verteilung eines solchen Impfjobs jetzt auch nicht so ganz einfach. Also äh zunächst einmal habe ich gehört, dass.
Die Lagerung des Impfstoffs ähm muss bei,
niedrigen Temperaturen stattfinden. So minus siebzig Grad.
Damit der sich hält, warum warum ist denn das überhaupt so.
Ähm.
Einerseits, das liegt vermutlich daran, dass diese diese Formulierung,
relativ instabil ist im Laufe der Zeit, RGNA ist für sich genommen.
Ja schon instabiler als MRNA.
Das hat allerdings im Vorfeld tatsächlich,
für eine gewisse Verwunderung in der Branche gesorgt, dass diese, dass diese Formulierung so instabil ist äh.
Offensichtlich muss das nicht sein, muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin da nicht so der der Pharmatechnik.
Dass ich das weiß, aber offensichtlich ist die Formulierung diese Lipidkapseln möglicherweise die MRNA selbst so instabil, dass man sie nicht bei Raumtemperatur lagern kann.
Also ich habe eine äh in so einem Interview,
Chef von Björn Tech, der meinte,
dass sie da auch noch dran arbeiten, dass sie diese Kühlung halt haben und sozusagen in der ersten Phase der Verteilung da ist auch nicht so das Problem sehen, weil das ohnehin erstmal über irgendwelche
äh geeigneten Impfzentren laufen würdet, also das quasi die Leute dahingehen, nicht der Impfstoff zu den Leuten kommt
und dass sie äh in Zukunft dann aber auch die Möglichkeit sehen, dass der Impfstoff sich dann
nach einer Verteilung an Orte, die jetzt nicht diese kühlen Möglichkeiten haben, äh auch für ein paar Tage in so einer normalen Kühlung, wie es so andere medizinische Zentren normalerweise haben, auch halten äh sollte.
Ja, äh das ist natürlich etwas, womit man ein bisschen rumexperimentieren mus
von Impfstoffen, das weiß man ja auch nicht, zum Beispiel Ärgern A für sich genommen äh
kann man durchaus bei Raumtemperaturen lagern, wenn das Zeug äh sehr, sehr rein ist und keine keine Abbauenden Enzyme da sind,
Es besteht auch die Möglichkeit, dass sie das Zeug bisher.
Tatsächlich nur bei minus acht äh minus siebzig Grad gelagert haben, äh weil sie wissen, dass es da stabil ist und einfach.
Überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, wie es sich bei bei höheren Temperaturen verhält.
Auch sein, also dass sie dass das quasi einfach äh der quasi die einzige Information ist, die sie haben,
Im Moment bereiten sich aber offensichtlich viele Zentren, viele Hospitäler darauf vor, dass man tatsächlich diese minus siebzig Grad braucht
denn äh ich habe neulich eine Nachricht,
dass jetzt tatsächlich äh,
Krankenhäuser in den USA anfangen, diese Tiefkühler aufzukaufen.
Ja, also die Hightech-Version vom Klopapierhamstern.
Was ist denn so dein.
Persönlicher Eindruck jetzt so von von dieser Geschichte? Stimmt dich das optimistisch? Bist du da zurückhaltend oder beides.
Also äh es ist natürlich eine super Sache, dass es diesen im Stoff gibt
dann ganz ehrlich, auch wenn wenn man da noch nicht nicht alle Daten hat, die man gerne hätte. Klar äh
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das alles, dass das alles komplett
Blödsinn ist, weil also allein na ja, ich meine, man man könnte sagen,
wenn wir jetzt eine Effektivität von was man ja erwartet hat, so dreißig, vier.
Wenn sie eine Effektivität von dreißig.
Gemeldet hätten. Äh dann könnte man sagen, na ja, da müssen wir jetzt aber ganz, ganz genau hingucken, ob da nicht mit,
geschummelt wurde. Ja, weil wenn man sich hinstellt und sagt,
dass.
Schon, das ist schon eine Zahl, die man mit weniger Fällen sagen kann, die man auch glaube ich, auf die man auch, glaube ich, nicht mit statistischen Tricks kommt. Also.
Ich würde davon ausgehen, tatsächlich vorläufig bei aller Vorsicht, dass das Ergebnis real ist und dass die tatsächlich da einen funktionierenden Impfstoff haben
Die Frage ist, was als nächstes passiert. Ja, ähm.
Du hast das ja schon angesprochen, die Verteilung ist ein Problem, dann äh werden,
natürlich nicht. Was weiß ich morgen oder am Tag
dann irgendwann was weiß ich, achtzig Millionen Impfdosen in Deutschland abgestellt werden und dann geht's ab, sondern äh man hat.
Anfang ähm eine also viel weniger im Stoff als man gerne hätte und da muss man sich jetzt erstmal überlegen.
Ja was was äh,
Was macht man eigentlich mit diesen vergleichsweise geringen Mengen im Stoffen? Und da gibt es äh.
Die nationale Impfstrategie in Deutschland, die dafür, also die,
beruht, dass man am Anfang wenig Impfstoff hat und diesen nach
offensichtlich noch zu klärenden Kriterien dann.
An spezifische Leute gibt, also
Beispiel erstmal die Beschäftigten des Gesundheitswesens oder äh ganz spezifisch irgendwelche äh.
Irgendwelche Risikogruppen das scheint mir tatsächlich dann erstmal die größere Frage zu sein
wann bekommt man diesen Impfstoff und was macht man, wenn man erstmal relativ wenige relativ wenige Dosen hat. Das heißt.
Wir stehen jetzt glaube ich erst am Anfang eines Prozesses, der vielleicht nicht ganz so einfach wird.
Man könnte sich ja verschiedene Strategien vorstellen, aber ich meine, dass das Personal in Krankenhäusern hier äh auf Platz eins steht. Ich denke, das steht komplett außer Frage. Das äh habe ich eigentlich auch noch nirgendswo anders diskutiert gesehen. Ähm das wird.
Meiner Auffassung nach äh auch so kommen. Dann ist ja die Frage.
Haben diese Tests, die jetzt durchgeführt wurden, auch in ausreichenden Maße alte Leute.
Berücksichtigt, wissen wir noch nicht, weil die Zahlen ja noch nicht veröffentlicht sind
Bei anderen Impfstoffen ist es ja oft so.
Dass eben auch die Anzahl der Dosen, also dass die Dosierung,
Ja, die Menge an Impfstoff, die hier zum Einsatz kommen muss, um Sommer mal siebzig, Achtzigjährige auch entsprechend.
Zu schützen unter Umständen noch sehr viel höher ist, weil das Immunsystem nicht in dem Maße funktioniert, wie das bei jüngeren Leuten der Fall ist.
Sodass sozusagen diese Anzahl von Dosierungen sicher auch schnell teilt, ne? Also allein schon hundert Millionen Dosen, zwei Mal impfen sind schon nur noch fünfzig Millionen, ne.
So, da ist die Bevölkerung schon nicht mal abgedeckt. Und wenn du jetzt eben bei älteren Leuten auch noch äh äh was weiß ich, drei oder vier äh Dosen äh verabreichen muss, dann wird's natürlich dementsprechend weniger. Aber das wäre ja zumindest schon mal sinnvoll,
die Altersgruppen, die halt jetzt auch primär vom Tod bedroht sind. Das kann man ja den Todeszahlen,
ablesen, dass dass die an erster Stelle sind. Auf der anderen Seite könnte man natürlich auch sagen, es wäre auch wichtig, die besonders mobilen und aktiven,
Leute der Gesellschaft, also die jüngeren Leute zu impfen, dam,
äh eben nicht weiter dazu beitragen, so aktiv den Virus zu verteilen.
Ja, das wird man alles klären müssen und was wir natürlich auch nicht wissen ist ähm.
Dieser ob dieser Impfstoff tatsächlich nur symptomatische Infektion äh verhütet.
Oder beziehungsweise mögliche,
möglicherweise gibt es asymptomatische Infektionen, die,
trotzdem auftreten, das heißt äh
die Impfstrategie langfristig und auch die Erfolgsaussichten
wie lang wir brauchen, um tatsächlich für 'n,
Also tatsächlich ähm Kuwit neunzehn loszuwerden. Das würde das natürlich auch beeinflussen. Also.
Das hängt, der hängt eben von diesen Daten ab, die wir noch nicht haben. Welche Strategie man da fährt.
Sind denn die Leute, die die jetzt an diesem Test teilgenommen haben, vermutlich, also werden die dann auch regelmäßig,
getestet, also PCR getestet, auf Virus getestet oder äh wenn da von Fällen die Rede ist, sind das jetzt sozusagen und diese klassischen Symptomatischen,
Fälle, wo Leute wirklich krank.
Was ich gelesen habe sind es tatsächlich symptomatische Fälle, weil äh
Wenn wir, wenn wir uns, wenn wir uns mal klar machen, um wie viele Leute es geht
Nun achtunddreißig, vierzigtausend Leute, die dann ja regelmäßig möglicherweise im Wochenrhythmus getestet werden mussten, um nicht irgendwie meine symptomlose Infektion zu verpassen. Das wäre natürlich ein
immenser Aufwand äh tatsächlich zu versuchen in dieser Versuchsgruppe, die die asymptomatischen Infektionen auch zu finden
wie gesagt, also ich habe in einem Pressebericht gelesen, dass es tatsächlich nur um symptomatische Infektionen ging und das erscheint mir auch plausibler.
Aber müsste man vielleicht dann nochmal in zukünftigen Studien dann äh mit entsprechenden Mitteln nachziehen.
Ja sicher, wenn er, wenn äh wenn das Trial vorbei ist, also wenn die Studie vorbei ist und das alles veröffentlicht wird, wird das natürlich klarer, aber vorher sind wir ein bisschen auf Spekulationen angewiesen.
Okay,
Würde sagen, wir halten's mal äh kurz und knapp und beobachten das mal weiter, was es hier äh äh Neues gibt, gibt ja auch ein paar andere Firmen, die im Prinzip noch äh auf der Liste stehen, demnächst mit irgendwelchen Impfstoffankündigungen.
Auf.
Sollten wir hoffen.
Darauf sollten wir hoffen, genau gut wäre das. Jetzt haben wir zumindest schon mal einen, das äh macht ja schon mal gute Laune. Ne.
Ja. Das auf jeden Fall. Also es ist es ist ein See bei Streif am Horizont, aber da ist noch viel zu tun.
Gut Lars, dann sage ich äh erstmal vielen Dank.
Ja, danke für das Gespräch immer wieder gerne.
Ja und dann hören wir uns bestimmt bald und ja vielen Dank ja an alle die hier reingeschaltet haben und weiter geht's dann auch mit Corona Wicklieder, wenn er wieder die Zahlen gerollt äh und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.